It's just so lazy. It's like a new level of lazy. 150,000 views
in 9 hours, by the way. Mexico wants to send them fuel. A bunch
of countries want to SEND THEM FUEL. TOTAL RE-MIGRATION
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY. I WATCHED THIS YOUTUBER, ACTUALLY
WE NEED TO SEND THEM all back. It blows my mind. They hate the
progressive left. They hate the sock them left so much that they're
like, "Actually Republicans are awesome. Republicans are correct."
To be like being a more pegasus video on Hasan's Cuba trip. Hasan's
Cuba trip was a disaster.
Isn't he there for like a week still? I feel like he's still
there for a while. Hasan is back and he's larping again. This
time he's gone to Cuba to stay in five-star hotels and meet celebrities
while the population is suffering. He claims the American government
forced him to stay in Why is the pop Hold on. Is he going to
Is he going to engage with why the population suffering at all?
Cuz that's basically my thing. You can go after Hasan, but you
have to be sh- on the American government 100 times more. Right?
If you're going to get mad at Hasan and even We'll get to the
concert thing a little bit later. If you're not pissed at the
government
way more than you're pissed at Hasan, you're out of your f- mind,
man.
Is he going there to talk about how they're suffering? I believe
he's also taking a huge amount of aid there,
Although with the lack of fuel, I don't know how much help a
lot of the aid is. Do they have camels they can load the aid
up onto carry it out and deliver it to people or five-star hotels
and he had no choice. He starts being explicitly racist talking
down to Cubans saying that they don't know anything about their
own country. He claims Miami Cubans are dumb because they think
communism is bad and he had to educate them. He casually mentions
hanging out with fellow terrorist supporters and how he'd, quote,
"pepper the people with cash. Real classy charity work. Ricegum
vibes. Ranked number one As Ion Orbiter, Bloba the Hutt is back
and she is fat shaming another commentary I mean, hold on. I'm
not going to lie, I do think she might get to do that. I think
she might be lower on the fatty totem pole, okay? Or higher depending
on how you Yeah, I guess you take the lighter people and put
them higher. I don't know how that works, okay? >> is back
and she is fat shaming another commentary creator. Absolute cinema.
She's beefing with a bunch of people on Twitter and posting thirst
traps.
Hasan is Did I I think I was discussing it off stream.
Bro can kind of pack it heat, okay? Once she loses the weight.
What the
Dude, I saw some pictures. Somebody linked me her Instagram and
I was like, "Jesus Christ."
She's got a permit for those? What the You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying? I I don't I'm not saying much, but
like Jesus, man. Trying to cancel Asmongold again and get him
banned. He's signaled I can see I can see I doubted your
I doubted your Semitic heritage. I doubted that you were from
the Levant, okay? I no longer doubt Frogon. I no longer doubt.
>> Boosting his fan account completely lying about Asmin
and maliciously editing him OUT OF CONTEXT.
ALL RIGHT. >> Now This has actually got a lot of the stuff.
This is going to be a good kickoff for this whole thing. Awesome.
Let's go.
>> Right, so Hasan is back and he's larping again. If you
remember, he was calling Cubans gross and telling them to shut
up and let the educated Hasan [__] tell them about
their country. Well, now he I Again, I If this guy doesn't mention
the oil embargo once,
it's actually crazy.
I don't know how you discuss this topic without without mentioning
the oil embargo. You literally can't. Like it's all within that
frame, and I have a feeling this guy's going to going to find
a way, okay? He's just going to say, "No, you're you're just
supporting a communist regime. You're You're just supporting
a communist regime and have zero understanding or
I guess intellectual to say why the people in Cuba are so right
now. He's gone to Cuba in the worst way possible. Here we got
a tweet, tone-deaf radicals flock into Havana staying in five-star
hotels while the island is in crisis, a mockery of Cuban people,
and we just got Diddy [__] there having a great time.
Puer responded the irony of protesting apartheid and then directly
participating in the tourism apartheid, traveling to villages
made for the Western elite that falsely portray the magic of
communism while the real Cubans, barred from that luxury, suffer
its reality. Why can't real Cubans have like economic bite, guys?
Is there a reason? Is there a reason Cuba's economy's been struggling
for the past like 20, 30 years? Sorry, did I say 20, 30 years?
Longer than that. Why is Cuba's economy been struggling for all
this time? And yeah, we got their whole squad, snakes on a plane,
commies take food and meds to victims of communism. Right here
we have the article, they're staying in luxury hotels and traveling
in air-conditioned buses as the rest of the island grapples with
a worsening economic crisis that starved it of electricity, food
A worsening economic crisis. Wait, what happened What happened?
Why are they having a worsening economic crisis, guys? What's
going What's going on there? This is just American propaganda?
Well, this is an Indian Canadian, okay? So, who better to do
American propaganda than an Indian Canadian, okay? food, water,
and medicine, the New Storm America convoy sends socialist from
North America and Europe to Cuba by air, sea, and land under
the guise of handing out 20 tons of humanitarian aid while nearly
the entire country is suffering from power outages lasting over
20 hours. The Are we going to talk about why or
Oh, is he going to skip? Cuban officials reported island-wide
blackout this week in the embattled communist nation of some
11 million people after President Trump in January threatened
tariffs on any nation selling it oil, effectively choking off
its energy supply.
Well, we're just not going to include that. We're just not going
to say it. We don't need to read that part. That part doesn't
matter. left is welcomed with air conditioning and wasteful electricity
consumption. More than 100 homes wouldn't be without power today
if the Castro regime didn't spend on communist propaganda with
the international left. This is a gigantic mockery of the entire
Cuban people. The left visits Cuba as if it were a party at a
zoo, and they go to admire the misery from a luxury hotel. It
is outrageous. And this is exactly what Hasan [__]
tries to do. This is level of performative activism where he
doesn't actually endure any of the hardships these people are
going through and just look
Do activists Dude, do activists have to endure the hardships
for which they
Hey, don't talk about rape culture unless you've been raped,
okay?
How dare you talk about rape culture when the actual are out
there not talking about it.
What the [__] are you talking about?
Where Where else would you hold this
This is looks at them as like cattle. Don't advocate for Gaza
unless you've had your entire family killed by Israel. What the
[__] are you saying?
like looking at them through a cage essentially. In fact, the
situation is just getting worse. Cuba faces second nationwide
blackout in a week. Let's check on Hasan. Did you see Cuba denied
diesel imported for the US Embassy? Thought that was kind of
funny. Oh, I do think that's kind of funny. I Yeah, I don't have
a I I hope they reappropriated it. I feel like they should be
doing that. Although, I guess any any like negative They probably
have to deny it at port of entry because if they try to take
it from the Americans there, that's probably going to be seen
as an act of war by which they can, you know, go and do whatever
the [__] they
Hasan responds, explains why he's staying in a five-star hotel
in Cuba. Yeah, this is going to be absolutely rich here. I was
saying, tourism is the lifeline for the Cuban economy as it stands
currently.
The government has very limited resources, and the American government
makes it illegal
for Americans to stay wherever they want when they're in Cuba.
They have to stay in what they've declared as five-star hotels,
right? I'm telling you all this because like even the five-star
hotels are not like, you they're it's not like this is what the
American government has declared five-star hotels, but
in comparison to the situation on the
it's it's a like it's a it's prosperity pretty much, and experiencing
that dichotomy is like definitely [__] me up, definitely.
I mean, if I were to ever if I I mean, not ever, but like I Perfectly
reasonable explanation.
I mean,
I do think he should just start saying, "Yeah, I'm staying at
a hotel, like a nice hotel." Obviously, I'm staying at a nice
hotel. Why would I not stay at a nice hotel?
What the [__] are you talking about, right? Okay,
so we're talking about the solar panels that went and they're
being used to power hospitals and stuff. Sure. Sure. I think
um they brought a lot of stuff. They couldn't bring fuel in,
I'm guessing.
So, the solar panels are good. I do wonder, like I said, Hasan's
not like streaming at night, like he's out here during the day.
I don't know what's going on. I don't know what the power range
it is. I'm guessing they are cognizant of this in some way and
are not just like absorbing as much much power off the grid as
they possibly can, right? He did say oh jeez. >> I I hope
to come back and when I do I'll probably not abide by the American
restrictions. Oh, okay. I see now. How could have I been so stupid?
He just has to stay in five-star hotels, guys.
If he stayed in a hotel they'd whine about it, too. That's just
so true, isn't it? Look at him larping in that hotel. Look at
him TOTALLY LARPING.
HE'S PRETENDING HE'S LIKE A CUBAN. He's like he's like belittling
their them and their suffering by by larping and pretending to
do It's actually like crazy how people act around this guy. It's
so funny. As he cannot help it. The American government is forcing
him to stay in these five-star hotels. No.
He would never pick a five-star hotel out of his own volition.
He's not in He's not known to indulge in any sort of luxury at
all, right? He He's not known to have, you know, Gucci bags,
live in a mansion on his own in Hollywood, or buy super cars.
He never does that. Nor does he ever go on luxury trips or Is
that a super car?
It's a Porsche. Is that Porsche like a I feel like super cars
are a different class of thing.
Like super cars are like way more expensive, right? Super cars
are like three, four, five hundred grand, and this car would
probably be like a hundred grand, right?
Am I crazy? >> buy super cars. He never does that. Nor
does he ever go on luxury trips or paid propaganda trips. You
know what Hasan actually wanted to do was to experience some
of the suffering, you know, he wanted to suffer like the rest
of the people, but unfortunately for Did he say that? Who said
that? Who said Who said Hasan wanted to suffer?
Dude, I How do people just make up all of these things? Bro,
I
Unfortunately, this is just like free content. You know what
I'm saying? I probably if I were It's just free content every
time. Right? I just push point out like, "Hey, you're kind of
being absurd right now." I don't know. I wish I just wish these
people didn't do this. I could do something else. But unfortunately,
somebody has to sit here and just go, "Aren't you being a little
crazy right now? Aren't you going a little too far right now?
Aren't you like a little too You're going like a little too far
right now, no?"
Damn. For him, he just can't. He's just too American. Please
feel for Sanya. He's forced to stay in a five-star hotel. Will
anybody think of the Hasan Pikers of this world? Please think
of the mon- He was criticized for staying in a five-star hotel,
then he explained it, and we've invented people crying about
it that he really wanted to live somewhere bad, and by the way,
I'm sure he would stay in a five-star hotel either way. Right?
Whether or not he was forced to stay there, I'm sure he would
stay somewhere nice. Probably where a bunch of other influencers
are staying. multimillionaire.
Dude, honestly, you cannot make this [__] up, bro.
This guy unironically goes, "Oh my god, guys, I have to stay
in a five-star hotel." You absolute champagne socialist.
Okay, here's a thought. How about you stop larping for once in
your goddamn life, you damn worm, you pathetic loser, dude. How
tone-deaf is this man? You're chilling in a five-star hotel while
the country is going through blackouts and the people are suffering,
struggling to get any sort of resources at all, and here you
are just wasting everything. And the worst part is he literally
admits in the same clip that he can actually stay in different
places, but he'll just do it next time. Yeah, he'll just do it
next time, guys. Of course, when he comes back. Hasan, didn't
you just say it was illegal? So, like, make up your mind, you
know? Pew responded, "The US makes five-star hotels in Cuba mandatory."
Did the American government make him fly first class, too? No,
no, the American government actually forced him to have a a home
in Hollywood. >> Wait, did Hasan not sail over? I Did he
just fly? He didn't even sail? What the [__] man?
What the [__] Jesus Christ. >> It is well.
They forced him to buy Kaya, the most expensive
designer dog, of course. They forced him to buy the shotgun.
Oh, wait, no. That was Israel, guys. My bad. Why does he lie
so blatantly and frequently? Because lying is OP, according to
him. >> Lying is OP, as I say all the time. The American
government makes it illegal for Americans to stay wherever they
want when they're in Cuba. Fact check, this claim is misleading
and overstated. The US government does not make it illegal for
Americans to stay wherever they want in Cuba in the absolute
sense, but it does impose targeted restrictions on lodging as
part of broader Cuba sanctions administered by the Treasury Department's
Office of Foreign Assets and the State Department. Tourist travel
to Cuba is prohibited for by statute for US persons. Americans
can only travel under one of the 12 authorized categories. Humanitarian
projects, journalistic work. This must be Hasan, of course. Pure
tourism is not allowed, which he he literally describes being
a tourist there, by the way, enjoying all tourist things. Specific
lodging since 2020 Did he thought I thought he Dude, they brought
a bunch of aid. What the
They literally unloaded a bunch of this aid from the boats and
[__] What the [__] are we saying?
Like, he's documenting it.
Uh man, this is like so It's just so lazy. It's like a new level
of lazy. 150,000 views in 9 hours, by the way. Man, I
It's It's just crazy to me
that this guy can just go on here and be like, "Oh, well, I I
guess he's like humanitarian or journalist or
Yes, that's technically what he is. >> When the US persons
are generally barred from lodging, paying for lodging, or making
reservations at properties on the State Department's prohibited
list, these places are identified and controlled by So, essentially,
there is some truth to what he's saying. There is like some restriction
to whatever. He's only admitting this because he thinks the Gabe
Hoffman thing is correct, which it might be. I literally I the
Gabe Hoffman thing seemed like basically he didn't have the proof
of what he was saying. But, I wouldn't be shocked if he was correct.
Like, it's not impossible that he was correct that they're staying
at the place that has some electricity at Right? That's not impossible
at all.
Right? But, the curtains didn't match. Nothing he said like actually
was accurate there. So, I feel like that's why Pegasaurus is
doing this right now. He's He's just trying to set it up so he
could go, "But, actually Hasan is staying somewhere illegal.
He's illegally staying somewhere like a five-star hotel." But,
nobody's forcing him to go there and waste a bunch of resources
and forcing him to stay in five-star hotels. You could just stay
in [__] America,
In short, US rules heavily restrict hotel choices, but they do
not force luxury or five-star stays. They steer people towards
cheaper, private, independent lodging to avoid benefiting the
Cuban government or military. The clip exaggerates the restrictions
into a forced luxury narrative for rhetorical effect. Now, Hasan
would never exaggerate anything. He He's He's never lied. I've
never seen Hasan [__] tell a lie in my life. Apparently,
his trip was so bad we got DGG Destiny chiming in. Destiny calls
out Hasan's flotilla trip becoming a flytilla. From flotilla
to flytilla, lmao. This MF going to go to a country experiencing
a blackout and humanitarian crisis and stream for 2 days in a
fully air-conditioned room wearing a $5,000
outfit with reliable power? Yes. Yes, exactly. I mean, this is
peak level of performative activism, dude. This This does not
give a single [__] He's just trying to bolster his
own reputation,
sort of convince people that he's oh this humanitarian.
Dude, it's I'm so much better when I just sit in my apartment
and criticize everybody. I'm like so much better than this guy.
I'm like always I'm always just so much better than these guys.
How dare Hasan?
Bro, I'm guessing Listen, I Is anybody doubting that Hasan would
have brought like a lot of donations, a lot of money to this
aid mission?
Is anybody doubting this at all?
Like just be real. If Hasan didn't do
what what could Hasan do here that would be good enough for people?
I actually don't know.
I I actually don't know.
It's like he went Did he have to Did he have to sail on the boat?
I laughed cuz he said he was going to go on the boats or something.
I think he said he was thinking about going on the boats. I I
wouldn't go on the boats. Dude, US government isn't pulling me
out of the water. No shot, right? Storm rolls in unexpectedly,
I'm not getting pulled out of the water by the US government.
No shot. I just It's It's so funny just this damned if you do,
damned if you don't thing. By the way, I think he's he's there
for like a photo op, yes. But his presence is positive.
I think he is there because it is both It is an alignment, okay?
Cuz unlike
Hasan can make the moral decision when it's convenient for his
platform as well, okay? And I think that's what happened here.
But people won't accept that. They won't accept like yeah, he
gains from it and it's also like a good thing to do.
It's It's both at the same time.
It's obviously both at the same time. And freaking out about
it is very funny.
Kyle Kulinski, I'm referencing the previous video or the previous
segment we did, obviously. caring trying to help the people meanwhile
living in flipping luxury and actually actively hurting the people
there with his propaganda. Do you think he'll shake hands with
the poorest or is he just speaking to paid propagandists like
himself? Oh no, he was mingling with a bunch of celebrities as
we'll see. I got my favorite show. Two ring gods fighting, classic.
Moving on to Hassan being explicitly racist again, talking down
to Cubans because he's the enlightened one. I feel like this
guy's going to totally build this up and I'm going to be like,
oh, the only bad thing about Hassan is finally fixed. HE CAN'T
BE RACIST.
OH, NO, HASSAN. AND NOW he's he's basically baiting me thinking
Hassan will be racist and Hassan's not going to be racist, is
he? I feel like I'm getting lied to.
Woke warrior of the radical left here. Hassan explains the difference
between Miami Cubans and Cubans in Cuba. Also real quick, sorry
for the glitchiness of this clip. Apparently the five-star hotel
Wi-Fi ain't great here. I don't know if he's using like Starlink
or something, God knows. Cubans
[__] best people, okay? So kind, so welcoming, just
the best, just the absolute
It's just going to be anti-Diaspora stuff. Yep. Yep.
But I I can't possibly Oh my God.
I couldn't possibly be more anti-Diaspora pilled on like any
anymore. Like it's Dude, the Iranian thing has like actually
destroyed my
The Iranian Diaspora just basically totally
building up all of the storylines with no clue what goes on in
that country to get that country like essentially just [__]
destroyed.
I actually
I'm now like totally anti-Diaspora'd pilled. It's like actually
crazy.
Dude, the I don't know about the Cuban ones as much. I'm guessing
it's very similar, okay? I don't think it's fair to compare every
Diaspora group to the Iranian Diaspora. Dude, the Iranians are
[__] out of their minds.
best people. Oh my lord. Okay? Anyway, but yeah, we we worked
hard and we were able to uh we were able to set up a we were
able to set up a goddamn stream, you know? Not in Miami. Oh,
dude, it's the reversal.
That's literally like the exact opposite. Like all the good Cubans
stayed here.
And most of the most of the ones that are crazy is like flew
up there. I swear to god. I had a really funny experience is
like we get in the car we get in the we get in the Uber last
night. March and I about to discuss
that we're going to be flying to Cuba like talking about plans,
right? And I was like, "March, don't say anything." Cuz I noticed
that the dude in the car was a Miami Cuban. I was like, "Don't
Like I literally went
don't say anything." Dude, that's so
That's so funny. That's so funny. >> I was like, "Where
are you from?" And he's like, "Oh, Cuba." And I was like, "Okay."
And I just asked him about like, you know, what his feelings
are about what's going on. March actually spat some some Spanish
at him. And and let me tell you, okay?
He said, "Donald Trump needs to finish the job." Right.
Okay, Hassan. So, the Cubans are great guys, but only the ones
I approve of, right? The ones who disagree with me
he just This isn't really racist. Hassan asked the guy. Hassan
went, "Hey, I'm not going to let my bias be the only thing here.
I'm going to talk to this guy directly. Oh, wait, he's exactly
what I thought. And the the reason I told that guy to shut up,
that was totally founded. And but I he made sure, okay? He didn't
want to judge that guy without speaking to him.
I hope Donald Trump finishes the job. No, no, I hate them. They
flipping suck. They don't even know anything. They're self-hating.
They're probably racist. I, Hassan [__] will educate
them, right? The Hasan [__] the lover of minorities,
right? Unless they obviously practice any level of critical thought,
unless they actually disagree with him, then he just brings out
the white supremacist mode, the real racism mode. Yo, [__]
this refugee, okay? Seriously, [__] this South Vietnamese
whatever like want to go back and live in South Vietnam in the
same conditions. >> Any other black folk want to engage
in radical activist language in this chat? Suck my Black people
care about the border. I don't give a [__] what black
people care about. Oh, black people CARE ABOUT THIS, BLACK PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT THAT. LIKE SHUT THE I mean, honestly, I can't believe
like how Hasan [__] highlight reel, let's [__]
go. >> he actually is with the [__] saying
that, yeah, I love these cute Cubans who actually agree with
me and I hate the Cubans who dare to criticize communism. Oh
my god, they don't know anything. Absolute pathetic hypocrite,
bro. So then he goes on to say that, oh my god, these Miami Cubans
are so stupid. They think that communism is bad and, you know,
I actually had to educate them. I had to be careful around them.
Well, unfortunately, that's not necessarily like even with the
guy was
I think you could boil this entirely down to, do you think the
energy blockade is good? Do you think the fact that Cubans can't
like get their food, they can't distribute food, they can't grow
food, that they are totally as a country? That That's what it
boils down to, right? And he's The guy said, I hope Donald Trump
finishes the job. It's like, oh, well, I see where you're landing
on this. Literally racially profiling. said Donald Trump
needs to finish the job.
That's what he said. That was the first guy. And this is like,
I guess this was March's first real interaction
with like a Miami Cuban, you know what I mean? This was his first
ever interaction with a real Miami Cuban, like a real ass Miami
Cuban, right? So he was like kind of shocked. And
I know I know what the stream abs look like, megafonix. I'm monitoring
it. I'm monitoring the situation and I'm monitoring the stream
as well.
So Marjorie not experienced that at all. So there was that was
like his first ever inclination. The guy had no He didn't realize
just how bad the Miami Cubans were, okay? No family. Did Cubans
Why Why would you even ask this question Majrooks?
Did Cubans get fuel from Venezuela and Iran? I have no idea.
That has nothing to do with the energy blockade going on in the
country.
Here they were all in Miami, right? So like, you know, obviously
he was he was the classic like, you know, bomb it all like God
sort it out type guy. >> Wait, it literally doesn't matter.
The answer to that question doesn't matter because it it literally
is irrelevant. Mexico wants to send them fuel. A bunch of countries
want to send them fuel.
They've been petitioning the US government to be allowed to send
them fuel to to alleviate the humanitarian crisis. So who they
got oil from before literally does not matter whatsoever.
What matters is they're being blocked from being able to continue
their country. It matters to the orange man. Well, thank God.
I forgot Donald Trump's usually reasonable. He has really great,
you know, really great great ideas of what countries should and
shouldn't do. Sorry. Yeah. Yeah, shouldn't and shouldn't do.
Yeah, he's got really great Dude, awesome. We We love Donald
Trump now.
This is This is the level that a lot of people, not just you
Majrooks, but a lot of other people are just finding that they
agree with Republicans now.
Dude, Hasan Piker's in Cuba? Um actually Donald Trump was right.
Actually, hold on. Donald Trump was right and Republicans were
right. I've seen this a couple different times in the past like
three or four days. Not only over Hasan. I just see a lot of
like liberals starting to agree with Republicans and it blows
my [__] mind.
It blows my mind that people like they hate the progressive left.
They hate the socialist the the soc dem left so much that they're
like actually Republicans are awesome. Republicans are correct.
Oh, you you think the Iran war operation was really bad? You
Oh, so so you just like you think Iran's great then. You love
the Iranian regime. No? Oh, well, wait, you know what? Huh, Donald
Trump actually made the right call. Donald Trump actually made
the right call in bombing Iran. Uh, okay. Did he make the right
call in threatening to bomb power stations that power civilian
centers?
It's very funny. It's very funny where this whole thing's going.
Realignment political realignment in the weirdest way. We love
collective punishment mass starvation now. Yeah. Dude, that's
what they love. How do these people then go and with a straight
face argue for USAID? I have no idea. How do you possibly criticize
Donald Trump for cutting USAID and then advocate for the operation
in Iran? Blows my mind. And then this morning we had another
conversation, but this guy was actually so so on Trump and he
was still like, "Oh, the government is like stealing everything.
It's bad. Blah blah blah. Communism is bad."
But Oh, let's go. >> bit more open-minded cuz I was able
to like talk to him about the embargo. You know, they have this
very weird attitude about it. They have this very weird attitude
about it. On the one hand, they kind of they understand what
their what their families' lives looked like or felt like when
there was a little bit of sanctions relief and like they could
send money with ease to their families. You know what I mean?
Like
it's just such a strange cognitive dissonance to experience in
real time,
you know, I I gave a couple interviews on the at the airport
and stuff and then So, he just explained the energy blockade.
He didn't explain why communism is correct, right? He just explained
the energy blockade. That's way different. Okay. >> And we
flew in. Hasan, you're such a dork, dude. This guy cannot help
but constantly explicitly talk down to groups of people all the
time and it is so annoying, bro. It is so annoying. Let Mr. Peiker
here tell you how communism will actually save the world, right?
That's literally not what he said at all. This guy's functionally
[__]
I I've been very supportive of my Indian-Canadian brothers, but
now this person is actually turning me into the dude from the
the Tyler Oliveira video, okay? That guy who's like I'm turning
into that guy very slowly. And Mort Pegasar is the guy sending
me there, okay? I'm slowly becoming very very
and it's up that this guy is doing it by himself, okay? How about
you just
How about you just listen to the things being said? As he's actively
needing to provide humanitarian aid as communism is totally definitely
not leading to all of this hardship. Let him actually It's totally
not definitely leading to all of this hardship. Communism, I
do believe, has
honestly, in a lot of ways, hurt the Cuban economy. I do believe
that. Even beyond the the trade embargoes and stuff, I do believe
communism is not a good economic model, especially for not a
less especially not for a lesser power like Cuba, okay? I I don't
think so. But but
the embargo has a huge effect, and this this trade Sorry, the
overall Cuban embargo has a huge effect, and the trade embargo
on oil now has a far larger effect, okay? This is not communist
mismanagement that is leading to this country disintegrating.
It is the US explicitly trying to starve them into overthrowing
their government.
That is what the US is planning. We're going to starve these
people to death, and then once enough people have died, they'll
overthrow their government for us. That's literally the plan.
That's why I said if you discuss this issue without understanding
the embargo or anything going on there, it's it's
a problem. You can't have the conversation. You need to understand
something of the politics going on. And this guy actually skips
the part of the article that explains why the country's experiencing
these rolling blackouts, why they can't grow food, why they can't
do anything. To we educate you on the benefits of dictators,
right? And if you disagree, then you're an uneducated
Cuban loser or whatever. You're a war-hungry loser. You're probably
a Trump supporter, a Nazi, an Israel denier. Yeah, no, Hasan
Honestly, these things do He said all of that. Hasan didn't say
that. He's like straw manning Hasan. But actually, unironically,
if you're the person supporting this, I feel like I'd bet I'd
take like five to one odds that you are a massive Israel denier.
Yes, 100% I would. If you understand the politics and you're
doing this, you are just an Israel denier if you're if you're
accepting this as well, okay? This is all This is all descended
from the same school of thought on international law and what
the appropriate relationship is between the United States and
the rest of the world,
All of this So, Hasan didn't say it, but I'll say it. You You're
obviously just like an Israel denier if you or you obviously
are way more likely to be an Israel denier if you think like
this is good this this American policy is good. Which it's funny
It's funny how obviously it lines up. Like all of the liberal
Zionists are the people who would stand behind this, who are
like good with it. Who make no comment about it, right? It's
wild.
It's wild how like obvious the lineup is. Done, some people actually
just use common sense thinking. This isn't even about politics,
it's about hey, can you And then, by the way, and then people
will be like, "No, no, no, no, no. I don't know. I I'm like not
Israel first." It's like, "Okay, you just You flipped your politics
to supporting Trump because of Israel." Unironically, that's
what you've done.
You You now support like totally insane Trump decisions because
you support
And you're trying to stay consistent. and open your eyes. They
realize that, hey, there's a humanitarian crisis. The situation
is not good. The thing that caused this situation is also probably
not good. But don't worry, Hasan is coming in on his private
jet to save you. He's coming in in his air-conditioned car, in
his five-star hotel, you know, taking the limited resources and
power in order to do more propaganda. And then he'll get in his
little bus ride there, and then look at the cumans, make sure
not to touch, guys. Literally like a disgusting like poverty
tourist, right?
Is nobody going to point out that air conditioning doesn't work
without a sealed like vehicle?
Like it's obviously not air-conditioned
because it's not a sealed system.
Air conditioning literally only works in a sealed system.
Like it obviously wouldn't work in an open-air bus.
Are we just completely
Are we just making this up as we go?
Remember during COVID how like supermarkets and stuff would spread
be like super spreader locations because they have a closed system,
closed air conditioning system?
People are so [__] stupid.
Dude, it's crazy.
But yeah, good job, Hasan. Next stop will be North Korea. They
will welcome you with open arms. They'll be like, "You know,
this lovely American here. See, the Americans actually love us,
you know. We are a democracy here. No oppression, no oppression.
It's all US propaganda." He'll be totally chill. He'll take a
little selfie with Kim Jong-un. Best buddies, right? But by the
way, if Hasan did that, if Hasan went and swept for the North
Korean regime, then you could criticize him. Then he would be
like criticizable,
right? Although then again, if if basically the US was intentionally
like blockading North Korea, if they're if they're stopping trade
with North Korea with the explicit goal of like starving
then I I think if he was taking food, it might be hard to criticize
him then,
Dude, it's it might actually be hard. If they were like trying
to put the boot down on North Korea and starve everybody to death,
that that would be difficult. If he's just taking aid, if he
was like getting a whole bunch of donations solicited so they
could buy a whole bunch of stuff, take solar panels, take aid,
right?
It might actually be hard to criticize him there, too. >> there.
Miami Cuban. Notice how the left are incredibly racist and ignorant.
If you decided to migrate somewhere because you want to leave
a communist regime making the people suffer, listen, I wouldn't
group everyone in this. He's like the worst representation and
the fact that he's like the biggest leftist streamer is just
doing a innumerable damage to any sort of agenda. This piece
of [__] is more racist than Donald Trump innumerable
damage to any agenda. This guy is literally doing
He's actually doing like pro-Trump propaganda. That's what this
video is,
This video is unironically pro-Trump propaganda and he's Hassan
is doing innumerable damage to many political >> Trump
could ever be, by the way. He had one interaction and now he
is ready to
Was this guy born here? Was this guy born here? Cuz I'm about
to start, okay?
About to start We're about to start the Canadian the Canada first
movement, OKAY? TOTAL REMIGRATION
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY. I WATCHED THIS YOUTUBER. ACTUALLY,
WE NEED TO SEND THEM ALL BACK, OKAY? They all need to go back.
Okay, it's about to happen. If he was born here, then I can't,
but if he wasn't born here, oh boy. >> Just speak on behalf
of the 11 million Cubans residing in the country. He has been
on Cuban soil for only a few short hours and already sees himself
as the Cuban Messiah. I'm not sure what's worse about Hassan
[__] his narcissism or his mental retardation. I
mean, he did the same to Canada, right? He landed and he's like,
"Well, why doesn't everybody just go to Canada? I've been here
for 25 minutes and it seems better than the US to me. You may
Yeah, that's like totally performative. Yeah, that's obviously
totally
I don't know if does more Pegasus realize this? When you go to
a concert and they talk about loving the city they're in, "WE
LOVE CLEVELAND!"
NOBODY LOVES CLEVELAND, BRO. They actually just do that cuz Cuz
landing in the place and they're like going, "Hey, I love everybody
here. Come see me. Come I'm I'm a person who influences.
Nobody loves Cleveland, okay? Except maybe
LeBron may be the only one. Nobody else likes Cleveland. Everybody
just go to Canada. I've been here for 25 minutes and it seems
better than the US to me. You may not like it, but this is what
peak streaming looks like under communism and uh Yep. So I mean,
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I've heard it described and I
know the pattern cuz for a while I didn't have my Starlink set
up at my cabin very well, so it would cut out in this exact way.
If he was cutting out every 90 seconds or so, that's how long
it takes to daisy chain to move, okay?
It's then he's just using Starlink. So actually, this is like
peak innovation,
Starlink's super bad during like around the equator though, which
I'm guessing Cuba is pretty close.
It's as clear as day. >> Keep going. I can still see this
diddy [__] outline here. Bro's upset that Cubans
who live in poverty and filth would like to live in a better
country. Dude, yeah, actually, if you if you just get off at
YVR and you take the train somewhere, dude, Vancouver is like
the nicest city. If you thought Vancouver's with the Vancouver
is unironically like a next-level Canadian city, okay? You think
all of it is like Vancouver and that's where he went. Unfortunately
for
that's just not the case, okay? Vancouver's pretty awesome. At
least from the times I've gone, Vancouver's pretty awesome. country.
They can barely afford food and basic necessities, but at least
they have free health care. Wow, these people in extreme poverty
are so nice to me. Yeah, must be your charming personality and
not the US dollars you're throwing around. He's really delusional.
He can't tell that Miami Cubans want to go back home to a free
and prosperous Cuba, but the No, they don't. No, they don't.
If Cuba was a democracy tomorrow, zero Miami Cubans would would
go back to Cuba unless they could get their property back, okay?
They like living in the States. The America is a better country
than Cuba under the best conditions. I'm sorry to say, okay?
If they're American citizens, they're not going back to Cuba.
Nobody wants to do that. They're just ass mad about what's going
on in
Cubans living there now can only live day-to-day putting on a
smile to the wealthy foreigner hoping he will be graceful and
spare him a day of struggle. Both Cubans are hoping for the same
future. They just live in different places. The Cubans that the
government allowed me to speak to only had positive things to
say. You don't say. Moving on to Hassan talking about what he
did in Cuba. Hassan talks about the beauty of Cuba and what he
did after his first broadcast linked up This one was also I will
this is the one moment where I'm not going to defend Hassan.
I
I hear it and I'm just like, bro, I I don't take you seriously
when you say these things. I'm I'm I'm overcome with >> Kick the
kneecap boys. Yes. But of course he's going to say all of the
things he said here, okay?
This is the one thing where I'm like, I find this cringe. But
I would find it cringe. I'm like a totally I'm a total cynic.
I'd find it cringe. I just ignore, okay? Hello terrorist supporters.
People are partying in the streets. They are just chilling. They
are just chilling, guys. Being chilling. >> Um like last
night we ended the broadcast and I went and linked up with the
progressive international boys. I met Jeremy Corbyn. That was
fantastic.
Uh Oh [__] >> And and I hung out with the kneecap
boys. We went out and uh and and drank at like a local establishment.
Honestly, we've just been living life, living large and uh you
know, just peppering people with uh with just wads of cash for
the most part uh with hopes that, you know, there's like a little
bit of economic respite for each individual.
That sounds like some earnest charity work, guys. So, Hassan
was just out there peppering people with wads of cash. Yeah,
uh
Should he not or Maybe you could have saved some saved some money
from those five-star hotels there. But yeah, essentially he's
saying that he was pulling a RiceGum, right? Does this guy think
Hasan needs to save money to spend money in other places or >> Making
it rain on the homeless person type [__] here. I
mean, that's basically how he's talking. It's not really like
a respectful way to put it at all. I mean, leave it to Hasan
to do charity work in like the worst way possible, right? In
the most disrespectful,
demeaning way you could possibly think.
Don't know how he handed the money to them. He didn't literally
He said peppering. It's like a figure of It's an
He didn't literally throw it at their
Dude, I don't Ah! It's like an expression. He's like giving away
a lot of money to people. By the way, there's like There's totally
like you could honestly criticize it. Well, does the cash help
them not starve right now? Does it help them like any of their
family members not starve? No.
But he also brought aid, so I don't know. There's like ways you
can actually criticize this. >> think of. >> You
know, takes a stack of cash, just lobs it lobs it into the crowd,
watches a bunch of people squirm. Let them eat cake. Yeah, also
he casually mentions that he hung out with the kneecap boys.
And if you don't know these guys, they are fellow terror supporters
right up there with Hasan [__] Very open and blatant
with this [__] Uh open where his allegiances lie,
you know, openly anti-Semitic, collabing with Mike from PA. Completely
shameless guy. Like he's just not walk back any of this. It's
It's very obvious what he actually thinks, you know? So, then
he talks about how he was just overcome with emotion, obviously.
Dude, why does he have to walk it back? >> seeing all these
poor people, it just lights a fire in the in the socialist heart.
Uh
Cuban that we encounter.
Um a lot of the info that you hear and see from the island is
like
uh directly coming from like most of the time like National Endowment
for Democracy Foundation backed uh individuals, you know, State
Department propaganda things like that. But, in any case, um
I am overcome with emotions at the beauty of this island and
the beauty of the people. Okay, the beauty thing is what made
me cringe. I'm sure I'm sure the National Endowment for Democracy
Fund is actually doing some character. >> It's uh it's
incredible. It's it's truly one of my favorite places officially.
I totally understand why Will was saying that about Cuba. Um
it's remarkable. The people's resilience is remarkable. There's
I mean there's like rolling blackouts that take place throughout
the day every day all around the country, right? 11 million people.
But, today's a beautiful day out here. It's like uh 75°, sunny.
People are partying. People are partying in the [__]
streets. They're I don't know if it's like an island mindset.
I don't know if it's like
I don't know if that has something to do with it. I'm sure that
has something to do with it, but like they're just chilling.
Like Cubans just they they vibe. They chill. They just literally
vibe. It don't matter. Like it's it's incredible.
Yeah, there's like festival
I assume this is I do think like you go to island
You like island places, people do sit outside a lot more. There's
like something about the climate that does create like a culture
where you're just like sitting chilling outside all the time.
I don't think that's like weird. I don't know what he's trying
to imply. I'm sure they're not out partying with no power and
every everywhere, like all around, there's like little mini festivals
that they put forward, like like block parties that they do.
It's global South mindset. South Africa is the same. Ah, yes,
of course. I am overcome with emotion, guys. You know, when I
pepper these people with some cash, you know, when I open the
window of my five-star hotel and you know, drop some cash out
the window, make it rain. Like the level of Yeah, the level of
um
like narrative we've that he just has to build his own story
the whole time, right? He can't actually work off of the thing
said. He just has to like Guys, when when Hasan opens the window
of his five-star
hotel and just throws money down, he thinks he's like helping
the
He's not. Yeah, I don't Okay. >> And you know, I'm just
overcome with emotions. The people are partying in the streets
for me. They are so excited to see Hasan [__] of
course. Specifically Hasan, not his money. Great job, Hasan.
You are the Messiah. You totally saved the people. Thank you
for your humanitarian work. In fact, I don't think the work is
done, actually. I think you should move. I think you should move.
I think you should stay there. I mean, the people obviously love
you, right? And you love communism. You love dictatorships. I
think I think you would enjoy it. >> I hate Hasan, but
at least he goes out and travels and tries to do things. Other
streamers just sit in filth and yell at their computer about
him. One like comment.
One like four comments. Migrants all day. What exactly is he
doing here other than harming the very cause that he's supposed
to be advocating for? Like every How Okay, he's going to make
the argument. So, I'd say he's probably bringing like a lot of
money, a lot of like there there'd probably be, you know, a lot
more aid going to this island based on him being involved. I'm
sure they took donations to buy things, right? Him being involved,
him supporting it would already bring in a ton of money that
wouldn't have been there otherwise, right?
So, there's there's that for one. I don't know what he could
contributed personally. I have no idea, okay? He's raising awareness
of this. He's getting people to talk about it. I'm not sure any
of these channels would have talked about it with out Hasan going,
right? And then I get to point out that No More Pegasus doesn't
even understand why the island is [__] up. Right?
So, we'll see what this guy says cuz he's saying he hurts the
he hurts the causes that he even claims to support. So, he's
got to be hurting the Cuban cause in some way, the even Cuban
communist cause, I guess. >> of propaganda he does on his
stream is bad news for the Cuban people. All these oppressed
groups hate Hasan. Hasan being What? What? Dude, even in like
the worst dude, even
Let's say there's some people living under the communist regime
that hate communism. They're aware of Hasan. Do you think they're
upset that Hasan's bringing like water to them? Do you think
the fact that he supports the government and they hate the government?
Do you think that's enough to make them like hate him right now
in this moment when he's like bringing eyes to the issue, the
fact that like people are starving there or going to be starving
soon, right? They might not be starving yet, but the whole point
of like an energy blockade is you can't farm, you can't you can't
distribute even the aid you get, right? You literally don't have
the the vehicles and the the oil or the the fuel, I should say,
not oil, the the gas or the fuel required to go distribute the
aid to to further out
You don't have these things, right? Yeah, he's taking solar panels
to try Why would they hate him for this? There's so many things
you could hate him for. I just there's no reason to think they
would hate him for this. There's no reason to suppose that he's
like ruining everything. I'm being truly relatable instead stays
at five-star hotels making tens of thousands of dollars taking
talking into a camera on the internet instead.
being truly relatable instead stays at five-star hotels I don't
think it's Hasan even streaming. Dude, how much has he streamed
for this? Hold on,
I'm guessing he understood he might not be able to stream that
much. Is he streaming the same amount? I feel like there's no
way.
He had a Two days ago, he had a three-hour stream and then yesterday
he had a 44-minute stream. So, he's taking time off of his stream
as well to go and do these things, right? Okay. Cool. Cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, Cool.
All right. Making tens of thousands of dollars talking to camera
on the internet instead. Just peppering people with wads of cash.
What is wrong with you? Do you feel proud of yourself that you
went to a failed dictatorship and are now, as you say, peppering
people with wads of cash? Am I the only one who sees what's wrong
with how he's acting? Nope, it's extremely tone deaf. Moving
on to Blabba the Hutt. Frogon is back and after consulting with
the law firms of Hogon and Doss, she is back in action. And apparently,
she's now going around calling someone else fat. She is fat shaming
someone else. Oh my lord, we have entered a different timeline
entirely. Anyways, it all started
Okay, we're going to do a silly voice. All right. >> Anisa
Jomha, you know, from the iDubbbz universe here, the Hasan [__]
universe, calling a commentary YouTuber fat. And he essentially
brings up Frogon in response. Nick D'Oreo responds after Anisa
called him out on the timeline. You can lose weight. Then Anisa
said, "Bro's ankles, dude. Look at these ankles. Look like they've
been pumped with salts and he needs a lymph- lymphatic drainage
stat. He looks like he has a rotation of goods." Yeah, I got
a rotation of goods that are all beige in color. I Huh? That
I don't even know what is he trying to say there.
What What is I He said it in a way that's like
It was It was a second innuendo. Rotation of goods. I don't I
don't even know what he's trying to say there. >> She had
the ability to edit this, I think. That's not my problem. Micronutrients
matter. Love your body. Take a multivitamin. So, it wasn't a
multivitamin. I just lost 100 lbs. That That kind of cleared
up the whole leg thing, but I appreciate your courtesy. Oh, yeah,
that's the other part. Dude, you know who caught the biggest
stray in this entire drama? This is like the Cathal thing when
she found out that everyone thinks she's ugly. Frogan just found
out that all of her friends think that she's disgusting. That's
the funniest part of this in Did he explain this at all? What
does he mean that Frogan found out all of her friends think she's
ugly?
Wait, what? What happened there? >> entire drama.
I mean I literally guys, I've been getting called fat for 7 years.
But Frogan just found out that all of her friends think she's
pathetic and gross. He lost 100 lb. How much did he weigh? Uh
he had to have been at least three bills here, right?
He he had to have been, you know,
15 He had to be three bills at like 5'8" or whatever, 5'6". gross.
That's the funniest ever. That is actually the funniest take
is that everybody like Close to 400? I He's very short, so it's
very unlikely he gets like close to 400 lb while still being
able to walk. >> legitimately fat. Like she found out
Chad said 400? Jesus Christ, man.
Right, okay. So, he's bringing up Frogan saying that okay, if
Anissa is making fun of me for being fat, then she's indirectly
making fun of Frogan, right? We got the Hassan fan, what a pathetic
little piggy. Well, Anissa called me a fat lard but talking about
Frogan, we ain't talking about Frogan, we're talking about your
fat ass, Mr. Eats Oreos. He loves to say Anyways, Frogan was
Reuben donated $3.
Three bills? Bro was three Williams. Okay, thank you. Thank you,
Reuben Reuben. Appreciate it,
What is the What is the next one? >> Eats Oreos. He loves
Why did he stop reading this comment? He loves to say, "Well,
I can lose the weight." but no, he never loses the weight. Why
did he Why did he stop reading that? to say, "Okay." Anyways,
Frogan responded to Oreo. Frogan seemingly subtweets Nick and
says she'll go pound for pound with him. All I'm going to say
is that when your chin and neck aren't one, then you can equate
yourself to me. Lmao. Okay, first off, nobody's equating themselves
to Frogan and Holy Galaxy. Let's go pound for pound. I will bring
my scale out and you bring yours. Winner gets a McFlurry. I know
you want badly, you fat [__] Okay, this is absolutely
crazy. Like Frogan finally found the one person that she can
actually go toe-to-toe with here. Holy [__] See,
there's a big That's like a 10-year-old photo right there. problem
here, pun not intended. The fact is usually when people make
a bunch of, you know, fat jokes, there's a, you know, nothing
she can really do to fight back. This is like the one case where
I I guess she could go pound for pound, I I I guess. I'm not
even a Dude, he can't This is rough. This is Sometimes you just
don't want to defend your your buddy, okay? Sometimes you're
never going to sound good defending your buddy, right? This is
one of those cases where maybe you just opt out of this fight,
right? I guess she could go pound for pound.
He's showing all the videos of Nick. Dude, it's rough to watch,
man. >> part of this [__] Keep my name out
of your damn mouth. I will never fat-shame anybody. Okay, that's
cap. That's cap. You just did it. You just did it. You literally
said when your chin and neck aren't one, you can equate yourself
You just did it. You lit- never fat-shame >> might have
been hypocritical here. I will never shame fat fat-shame anybody.
Oh, but if you want to She literally gives the caveat that she's
using.
She She says it and then she gives a caveat for that statement,
right?
anybody. Okay, that's cap. That's cap. You just did it. You just
did it. You literally said when your chin and neck aren't one,
you can equate yourself to me. So, you're saying that he's so
much fatter than you. You're literally making fun of him. That
is fat-shaming. You're literally just lying. Oh my god. I will
never fat-shame anybody, but if you want to come after me for
my weight and how I look, and you look like that, get the F out
of here, llama. Okay.
Yeah? Okay, so this is what I call a battle of the fat Okay,
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding, of course. Uh a battle
of the McFlurries. Winner gets a McFlurry tells you everything
you need to know. When a bigger person calls me fat. This is
I will say this is a particularly unique scenario. I'm not sure
what to do at this point. All of my gravity do I guess I could
make a planetary bodies joke, right? I surely. So, I guess this
is the equivalent of like two supermassive black holes colliding
or something. I don't know what's going to happen. Maybe another
universe spawns or something. He didn't He didn't show the most
recent Frogan picture, which by the way, she's like still overweight
or something. Like I'm not saying she lost all the weight, but
it's like
you can't really compare them unless Nick's lost like another
100 lb. Then they might be in the same ballpark. >> blame
her. McFlurry's kind of slap. I've actually never had one. So
much for being a progressive person, huh? The irony. Yeah, I
will say like I don't think the other guy is pretending to be
like a woke, you know, person. He doesn't make fun of fat people.
Oh god, is she coming on to Nick? Was that an attempt at flirting?
Uh I don't think this guy has anything to do with Destiny. I
This is just the HasanisBadAlgorithm,
okay? There's a whole HasanisBadAlgorithm that exists outside
of anything DGG adjacent. Don't read DGG into everything, okay?
It's just the HasanisBadAlgorithm
such that it exists on the internet. It's actually everywhere,
okay? This is the most powerful algorithm that exists amongst
drama farmers, okay? By far. >> The Oreo. I lost some weight,
but I'm still a fat F and you're a fat F, too. Frogan, coping
seed session about the level of obesity
for their graphs and statistics to prove that they're a massive
I feel like
I feel like the actual argument here is no, she's like an order
of magnitude less fat than Nick and
she's willing to say we can compare.
You're coping if you don't believe that. Jesus Christ, bro. This
is a crazy. Frogan responded, "Are you scared to say" Oh, also,
when you make them sound equal, you're just coping, obviously.
Hey Oreo, I don't know what care about is that you can tag him
if you like. I don't think she'd ever be scared to say Oreo.
In fact, that's probably something she says every day. Visual
context for those who don't know. Okay. Pish.
Dude, so how how do you think Nick feels when he watches all
these people do the videos? And they clearly, while like trying
to lukewarm defend him, bring up every terrible picture of him
to laugh at him. Like, he has to know that that's what all of
them are doing, right? Every single one of them gets every single
picture in their video to laugh at him. He understands that like
and then they do like, "Well, he's not like that bad, man. He's
like not that He's not that bad." Come on, he's not that Is he
that bad? I don't think he's that bad.
It's actually rough, dude. >> So, you can never cry about
fat phobia
Everyone be quiet. Right, so this person said, "Not saying he's
not fat as well, but your neck and chick are chin are one. I
don't understand why either of you would bring up weight." And
then she responds with a picture proving that her chin her neck
are not one. Holy. You know, I'll give credit where credit is
due. That's not bad. She seems to be making some progress if
that's not like an, you know, edited image or anything like that.
I don't know. I mean, good good Frogan, hopefully
Yeah, that's that's Frogan. She lost a bunch of weight. I made
a comment on this earlier. I will not go I will not comment further,
okay? I've already given all the commentary I'm willing to give
on this, okay?
It's like actually
Yeah, she's lost a bunch of weight. you're, you know, getting
healthy. Now, all you got to do is leave leave this terrorist
supporting, you know, radical woke cult that you're part of with
Hasan, and maybe you can become a decent person again, you know,
get a job. And yeah, you can stop begging for rent on stream,
and then everything will be nice and dandy. But this is a great
first step. This is a great first step. She's trying to frame
mug the If Frogan loses a bunch of weight and is like hot and
could just like cam up on
She She gained like a bunch of followers. She I It's It's actually
crazy. >> that she apparently stands a chance. By the way,
when she actually doesn't have the the hijab that clings tightly
to her chin, she looks way better, okay? She shouldn't cuz she's
always She's got the kind of face that it looks like it's going
to always have this or this is filler or something. I don't I
don't know. But, um just don't wear like the tight hijab that
makes you look like Thomas the Tank
That's all. Come on, man. >> chance. Right, we've got another
like commentator chiming in. I think it's wild for somebody who
has been
Dude, another commentator. He doesn't even say Glam's name. What
the [__]
Not even name Glam is Trust me, all the defense he did of the
attempted defense he did for Diiorio is all going to fall away
here. He will have no defense for Glam at all. There will be
no defense. Nothing even close, okay? body shamed online for
so many years to turn around and you have But, I think she's
mature. I think she's a mature >> These people These people
understand, okay? There's like a There's like a hierarchy, okay?
And it sucks. It's I Trust me.
I'm aware of how badly it sucks, okay? I used to be a very fat
person, all right, at one point very long time ago. And I understand
that but there's like there's a worse thing to be a fat guy,
okay? It's being a fat woman, being like a woman who is like
like this
size, okay?
It's That's like even worse than being uh like a fat guy. Being
a fat guy, you at least like get the benefit of the doubt on
like your opinions and stuff. Being a fat woman, people are just
like, "Fuck out of here,
It's rough. You got to be like especially like a fat white woman,
okay? You could be a fat black woman and make some things work,
all right? Fat black women have like a cultural thing going on
where they could at least have some contributions. Fat like massive
white women, there's no shot. Nope, doesn't work, doesn't happen.
>> mature. Just like all of her friends. So, I'm not surprised.
Like, "Ooh, you're fatter than me." Like girl, what are we doing?
What are we Yeah, I mean I think it's pretty hypocritical, but
I I guess she was just like fed up and trying to fight fire with
fire, I suppose. She responds again, "I've realized these people
want to use me as a punching bag because how am I the immature
one for finally responding to somebody after years of their one-sided
beef with me." So, apparently according to her, he was making
fun of her for years, so that's why. Anissa responds, "Correct."
Okay. So, now I immediately have to disagree. Immediately have
to disagree. If she's incorrect, must be wrong. Okay, and then
out of nowhere she started posting like
Uh okay. >> Start scraps or whatever. Right. Okay, we got
the frogan angles here. Anissa responds, "Mother. Such a baddie.
This Okay." Anyways, I'm going to refrain from commenting for
no particular reason, but I never thought I'd see a frogan mug
battle or like a fat on fat competition type like I don't know
what's happening. Just looks like a war of the Hasan peeps. Something
like that,
Um Hasan is bad. Hasan is very bad. If you heard this, Hasan
is bad. He's really bad.